strain my day Joe Rogan podcast one
night all day
it was ooh fighting in front of I mean I
was fighting in front of here like
40,000 people every time I went out
there swishes could have maintained I
thought I was a fan of it when when I
was even working for the UFC I was
always a big pride phantom-like look
this room for everybody of course you
know and just hang in there people that
were by having pride it opened up eyes I
would always say like having another
company with a different flavor
maybe it'll draw in other other fans
that would maybe necessarily be a fan of
the UFC but they like the way that pride
did it and so that would get them
interested in MMA and therefore then
they might also okay well maybe I will
give this UFC stuff a try maybe well I
like this one fighter so I'll watch when
he's on you know it's just yeah it
expands the market it doesn't diminish
it I think that's the same thing with
belt or yeah I really do I mean I think
that what what's good about Bellator is
that they're developing real world-class
talent now Michael Chandler
you know Michael venom page now Rory's
over there in his world-class talent
there you think it's true and you had
Mitrione fight field our place you know
crazy imagine a double knock down oh no
gets up first it's crazy crazy thing you
can't can't plan for or so a guy likes a
door when you see him at this stage of
his life and you see him getting K out
again what what are your thoughts on
that
you watch that it sucks to see that
that's the case I mean I love Matt
Mitrione to man he's a great dude I
trained him when I can and see him you
know get that victory it's a massive
victory as was I but I'm a friend and I
have been a friend of shoulders for such
a long time it's it's it sucks to see
him not doing well you've been saying
his name right it's a big commitment
that's like oh yes everybody else has
shade or yeah sure oh yeah other fancy
on us right like Doce asking shorter
yeah not Fedor okay
[Applause]
[Music]